yeah it seems your career has really
taken off since you did hot breath last
so
congratulations on that yes thank you
what would i do without you where would
i be
who would i need
and i saw you you were working with um
eddie murphy
on a new movie what was that like
working with eddie murphy
well there's two movies there's one
that's on netflix right now called
dolomite is my name
about the late rudy ray moore who
everybody didn't
know and um now
they have an opportunity to and uh
quickly after that i was asked to be
in asked to be in uh
or actually i was just cast and i wasn't
even asked there's no question
but to do the uh coming to america
sequel coming to america the quest
and um with the fact that every actor in
hollywood wants to be in that movie
uh hollywood and beyond mars and
the universe um i'm very pleased to be
in two eddie murphy movies back to back
um i got in that movie because of the
relationship with craig brewer and i
guess eddie
as well craig brewer is the director of
dolomite is my name he also
did hustle and flow and um is
doing did coming to america the quest
so i auditioned seven times i had seven
callbacks for dolomite is my name
so needless to say craig and i got to
know each other very very well
during those uh you know it was like the
old school screen test and everything
with the
wigs and the clothes and i felt very
hollywood but um
when this came along and i asked craig
how did i
get so lucky to end up in here he was
like well now i know what you can do
and you know i i really enjoyed you
and uh so you know i wanted to put you
in here which is a lesson to
you know young comics or even some old
ones and the lesson is don't be a dick
because nobody wants to work with a dick
but if you're nice and you're pleasant
and you're on time and you know your
lines and
you speak to the caterers and you're
nice to everybody and people are happy
to see your name on the call sheet
you could probably work for those people
again but if you come in there
on some deeper you know that that
word gets around too
so yeah yeah and you've worked with i
mean you've worked
adam sandler sasha baron cohen i mean my
i mean every
sandra bull like dm x bradley cooper
lady gaga beyonce
yeah so like what um are you people at
that
level of like success like are you is
there like a commonality you're seeing
between these people that
that maybe could rub off on to us that
are watching this
no because everybody no i
i don't because everybody is different
i will say that uh well
maybe i mean i will say that like sandra
bullock
bradley cooper gaga
beyonce um
mike myers anthony lopaglia john
they they have what the one common
thread is that they're very nice they're
very amenable
they're nice to the actors they're nice
to the crew they're not like
you know lee daniels who i heard as a
screaming lunatic
and they're they're uh are working for
tarantino who is
in fact a screaming lunatic but they get
the job done but
they're those people are very very nice
and it makes you
like if you got a kind of daddy issues
or whatever it makes you really want to
do your best
because they were so nice it makes you
want to please them
and get the um get the um
what's the word i'm looking for get the
um not accolades and accept and get the
approval of these people and i think
that's what comics won any damn way
is approval and love i think that's one
of the reasons that we do it it's one of
the reasons i do
yeah and what was it like eddie murphy
did you have any
memorable stories of getting to work
with him
oh for sure oh
for sure
let me see if i can tell anyway
um well first of all in dolomite is my
name
i actually auditioned for you have you
seen the movie i haven't no
wow i'm tripping yeah
i sort of want to hang up right now i
don't really watch netflix though to be
honest so i'm
yeah we're talking about eddie murphy
you're you are right
you're right yes jesus christ
how you even speak his name and you're
not up on his last two movies
after a comeback after not being on
film for like 20 years
now i just look like i'm trying to
appropriate his name now she's like
white boy just saying eddie murphy's
name
just for the come up whiteboard turning
red is a strawberry
okay um well in the movie dolomite is my
name
i actually auditioned seven times for
the part
of queen b uh lady reid who was his
who was dolomites like homegirl best
friend
cohort you know but i didn't get that
part they gave that part to an actress
by the name of divine joy randolph
who i really really appreciate and i'm
glad she got that part
because i got to play the part of
eddie's aunt of a rudy's aunt
who gave him the seed money to start his
um
own uh record company so to speak
and that meant that the scene was just
eddie
and i it wasn't in a group i didn't have
other actors it was just
eddie and i at the kitchen table
and he hugged on me and jumped on me and
kissed on me and stuff like that after i
gave him the money
or or after he thought he convinced me
to get the money
and so that was very minimal memorable
because
who doesn't want that now i want to
preface all this by saying
i did not meet eddie on the set i
already knew eddie murphy we already had
taken pictures together we'd already
been in
the club and parties together plus i was
very good friends
with his late brother charlie murphy and
we had made a movie together and we had
done something
so eddie was very familiar with who i
was i'm very familiar with anyway
had i not been introduced to him
many years prior i might would have
geeked totally the out
up my lines lost it sweated
farted
everything like that but i didn't do
that because i already
knew him i was just very honored to be
working with him because after seeing
boomerang and after seeing
uh norbert and after seeing uh harlem
nights and everything you don't dream in
your wildest dreams that you'll ever
really be
working with eddie and that you'll go
down in history on film with them and
not one but two movies
so you know i was very glad that it
worked out the way that it did
you know yeah that's just one story i
got some other that is so crazy i
can't even really tell you
but yes i've got stories with eddie for
sure
wait the story's on set or this happened
off the set
on set and off oh
oh that's fun well i i uh i shot
a pilot back in the day when uh charlie
murphy
was on the show and he just he would
have a story like he was just like the
best storyteller i've ever met it was
just incredible
i mean that's why uh
charlie murphy true hollywood stories on
the chapelle show
was so popular because charlie can tell
these damn story joe and
just the way he told him just be like oh
my god charlie please stop
like stop so yeah i really miss him he
was
yeah a great guy yeah they would come
out of nowhere like he could segue
into like a five minute story off you
sneezing or something he's like that
reminds me
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes oh that's so
cool
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips